Let's think about what might
happen if we had a solution of
this carboxylic acid here.
We might as well name it just
to get some practice.
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven carbons.
So this is heptan-, and then
we don't write heptane,
because this is a
carboxylic acid.
It is heptanoic acid.
So let's see what happens if
we have heptanoic acid
reacting with-- this is one, two
carbons, and then it has
an OH group, so this
is ethanol.
That's what the OH group does.
It makes this an alcohol.
And it's in the presence of a
sulfuric acid catalyst. This
right here is sulfuric acid,
one of the stronger acids.
I'll actually draw its
structure, because I always
find it frustrating when people
just write just the
formula here without the actual
structure, because the
structure actually shows
you why it's so acidic.
Sulfur has six valence
electrons, just like oxygen.
So it has a double bond to an
oxygen, another double bond to
an oxygen, and then it has a
single bond to an OH group,
and then it has another single
bond to an OH group.
And notice, it has one,
two, three, four,
five, six valence electrons.
Now, the reason why this is such
a strong acid, is that if
either of these oxygens take the
electron from this proton,
so actually give away the
proton to the solution,
there's a ton of resonance
structures here.
And maybe I'll make a whole
video on sulfuric acid, just
to show you all of the
resonance structures.
But, in general, whenever you
see a reaction when they say
it's catalyzed by an acid, all
you have to do is realize it's
just going to make the
surrounding solution a lot
more acidic, just a
ton more acidic.
Maybe we're in a solution of
ethanol, and if we are in a
solution of ethanol, it'll
just add protons to the
ethanol itself.
So you can imagine this
guy right over here.
Let me draw the sulfuric acid
a little bit differently.
Let me draw these
oxygen-hydrogen bonds, so you
have this oxygen and it is
bonded to a hydrogen there.
This is floating around
the solution.
You have your ethanol that
looks like this, so two
carbons and then bonded to an
oxygen, and then that oxygen
is bonded to a hydrogen.
The oxygen has two lone
pairs, just like that.
And so this guy really is good
at getting rid of the protons.
So you have a situation where
this electron can be taken
back by this oxygen, and then it
can actually be given here,
and there's all these resonance
structures.
But it's just very good at
taking that electron.
And that can happen at the exact
same time that one of
the ethanols capture the
hydrogen proton, at the exact
same time that this oxygen
captures that hydrogen proton.
And if you just look at this
part right here, this will
just result in-- this part alone
will just result in a
ton of having these protonated
ethanols flying around.
Actually, let me draw
it over here.
I want to make sure
I'm using my
screen real estate properly.
So this will result in a ton of
these protonated ethanols.
So one, two carbons, it
has this original
hydrogen over here.
But now it has one electron in
that original pair, and it
gave the other electron to this
hydrogen, so it gave the
other electron to that
hydrogen nucleus.
Let me do it in that
same color.
So it took a proton.
It gave away an electron, so it
now has a positive charge.
And now what was a sulfuric
acid now has a
negative charge over here.
So if I were to draw it, it
would now look like this.
Plus sulfur, two double
bonds, two oxygens.
You still have this OH group.
Actually, it could
still donate.
This is still acidic, but now
this oxygen right now gained
an electron.
It now has a negative charge.
Now, the whole reason I did this
is I wanted to give you a
tangible sense of what sulfuric
acid looks like and
why it's acidic.
But really, you just have to
kind of internalize that
you're just going to have a
bunch of hydrogen protons
floating around.
They could be attached
to an ethanol.
If this was a water solution,
they could create hydronium,
so you have a bunch of hydrogen
protons floating
around that will catalyze
this reaction.
They will be used to facilitate
the reaction we're
going to explore, and then
they will be let go.
So hopefully, this right here,
by having this right here, if
I start involving some of these
protonated ethanols in
our reaction, you won't view
that as a huge stretch of the
imagination, because they would
have gotten protonated
by the sulfuric acid.
Or if I just actually grab
protons in our reaction, that
actually might make it
a little bit simpler.
So let's start with the
actual reaction.
So let me read redraw
my heptanoic acid.
So I have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven
carbons, double bond to an
oxygen, and then we have an OH
group right over here.
Now, the first step of this
reaction, this oxygen right
here, we have all these protons
floating around, very
acidic environment.
We have sulfuric acid there just
giving protons away to
the ethanol or to
other things.
So this guy can grab a proton
either directly from sulfuric
acid or maybe from one
of the protonated
ethanols, either one.
So we could just draw
it like this.
He just grabs a hydrogen
proton.
The hydrogen proton might have
had an electron associated
with it that would then go back
to a sulfuric acid, but
just to make things simple, I'll
just say grabs a proton
from something else.
So once he grabs that proton,
then it looks like this.
So I'll draw my two, three,
four, five, six, seven
carbons, double bond to an
oxygen, single bond to an OH.
This oxygen had two lone pairs,
but now one of the lone
pairs is broken up because it
gave an electron to this
hydrogen proton right
over there.
Hydrogen proton, it was
positively charged.
It gained an electron.
Now it is neutral.
But this oxygen right over here
gave away the electron,
so it is now positive.
Now, the next step,
we have all this
ethanol floating around.
So let me introduce some
ethanol, and I'll do this in a
different color.
So we have this ethanol floating
around, and this is
one, two carbons.
This is our ethanol.
You have two electron pairs
on that oxygen.
And then you could imagine,
especially because this is now
a good leaving group, you can
imagine that this acts as a
nucleophile.
It would do a nucleophile attack
on this carbonyl carbon
right here.
And so what you could imagine is
that this electron attacks,
or gets given to, this carbon
right here on the carbonyl.
And at the exact same time that
this happens, this oxygen
is positively charged.
It wants an electron.
It wants to get neutral again.
It's already hogging
these electrons.
That's why you have
a partial positive
charge on this carbon.
That's why this guy might
be attracted to this.
We've see this in Sn2 reactions
many, many, many,
many times already.
So this electron will
be taken up by this
top oxygen over there.
So after that happens, what
does our newly formed
molecule look like?
Let me just scroll down and
have some clear space.
After that, our newly formed
molecule will look like this.
We have two, three, four, five,
six, seven carbons to
get to the carbonyl carbon, and
now it will have a single
bond to that oxygen up there.
That oxygen had one
lone pair already.
It had this bond to this
hydrogen that it nabbed from
the solution, that proton that
it nabbed from the solution,
and now it has another pair.
It had this electron that was
participating in a double bond
with this carbonyl carbon, but
now it took the other side of
that bond back.
So now it has that electron and
the other one that it took
from the carbon, so it has
two lone pairs again.
It had a positive charge, but
now it took back an electron.
Now, it is neutral.
Now the rest of the molecule,
we have this OH
group right over here.
We have that OH group
right over there.
And now we have the actual
ethanol that has attached
itself, so it is no
longer ethanol.
It's attached itself to
this larger molecule.
So this oxygen right over here,
it still has one lone
pair, but the other lone pair
has been broken up, and it has
given an electron
to this carbon.
It is now bonded to the larger
molecule, and then the rest of
it, you have these one, two
carbons right there, and then
you have this hydrogen
right over there.
Remember, we have a bunch of
protons floating around.
Actually, I should
make it clear.
These are all reversible
reactions, so I actually
shouldn't even draw one-way
arrows here.
Let me scratch that out.
Actually, delete that.
A better thing to do, instead
of drawing these one-way
arrows is to show that the
reaction could actually go in
either direction.
It's just as likely to go from
here to here as it is from
there to there.
So let me draw that.
These are kind of in equilibrium
with each other.
So you can imagine the next
thing that could happen is
another oxygen could grab a
proton from the medium.
And actually, before I do that,
let me make sure this
guy can lose a proton
to the medium.
Actually, this guy could take
the proton from that guy, but
I won't do it that way.
So you could imagine a situation
where this proton
just jumps off.
I should have pointed it out.
This guy gave away an electron
to this carbonyl carbon.
So this right here has
a positive charge.
In general, the oxygen, very
electronegative, it's going to
be hogging the electrons
of this proton, so it
can take them away.
So far, we gained a
proton, and now we
can give back a proton.
So this electron right here can
go back to this oxygen,
making it neutral.
And the proton can be picked
up by anything.
It could be picked up by another
molecule of heptanoic
acid through this first
protonation we saw.
It could be picked up by another
molecule of ethanol.
Let me draw it like that.
Let me draw it as getting picked
up by another molecule
of ethanol.
It just gets thrown back
in the solution.
So this guy gives an electron
to the proton, but the end
result is the hydrogen leaves.
The electron goes back
to the oxygen.
It now has a neutral charge.
And once again, these are all
reversible reactions.
It can go in either direction.
But we're now over here,
and let me redraw
my heptanoic acid.
Two, three, four, five, six,
seven single bond now to the
oxygen, single bond
to this OH.
And now we have this bond right
over here to this now
deprotonated, what was ethanol,
so you have O, and
then we have one, two carbons,
just like that.
And this guy has a hydrogen
attached to it.
And I won't even bother to draw
this protonated ethanol.
The protons are flying
around everywhere.
Now, the next step, this guy,
this OH group, and especially
the oxygen in it, he could
grab a proton from the
surrounding solution.
So he's got these
two lone pairs.
He can grab a proton from one
of these protonated ethanols
from the sulfuric acid, or maybe
from one of these other
intermediate molecules,
from anywhere.
That's the whole point of having
this acid catalyst, so
he could donate an electron
to a proton and then
form a bond with it.
I'll keep it in that color.
And so if that happened, then
the next step in our
reaction-- and remember,
these can all
go in either direction.
The next step in our reaction
will look like this.
You would have your two, three,
four, five, six, seven
carbons, single bond to an
oxygen, and then you have your
bond to this oxygen, which is
bound to two carbons, one, two
carbons, just like that.
And this guy on top is
bonded to an oxygen.
He's got two lone pairs.
And this guy over here
grabbed a proton.
He gave an electron to
a hydrogen proton.
He had two, but now he gave one
of them to this proton.
And so he gave it to
that hydrogen.
That hydrogen is now neutral.
It gained an electron.
This oxygen is now positive,
because it
gave away an electron.
It still has this other
lone pair over here.
It is now positive, and frankly,
it is now a good
leaving group.
So, in the next step, you
can have someone else.
Remember, other people
need protons
earlier in this reaction.
So this proton might get lost,
maybe by one of the other
ethanol molecules, so
let me draw that.
Let me do a color I
haven't used yet.
I'll use orange.
So maybe one of the other
ethanol molecules, or one of
the other intermediaries
in this whole reaction.
So ethanol, I'll just
do ethanol because
it's easier to draw.
It might give an electron
to just the nucleus.
And then this guy can take
the electron back.
This guy could take that
hydrogen's electron back and
give it to this carbon that
was the carbonyl carbon
several steps ago.
And then since he's got that
electron, he can then give
back this electron to this, what
was an OH group, but now
it's got another hydrogen there,
so he can then give it
back to him.
And then the resulting products
will look like this.
And this is all in
equilibrium.
We now have two, three, four,
five, six, seven carbons.
Now, this guy has a
double bond again.
So you have an oxygen
right there.
It is now a double bond.
I'll draw this newly formed
double bond in magenta.
This guy has left as water, so
I can just draw that, so now
you have this other OH group
that is bonded to this
hydrogen over here.
He has now left as water.
And now you have this other
thing over here.
You have what was that ethanol
group has now attached itself.
That ethanol has lost
its hydrogen.
It has attached itself to what
was a carboxylic acid, so now
it looks like this.
It now is bonded to an oxygen
and is bonded to one, two
carbons, just like that.
And this whole reaction that
I showed you is called
esterification, one of
those words that I
have trouble saying.
This one in particular
is called the Fischer
esterification.
And he won the Nobel Prize in
1902 generally for his work in
organic chemistry.
And the reason why it's called
that is we started with the
carboxylic acid.
We started with a heptanoic
acid, and
now we have an ester.
An ester is something that,
instead of an OH group like
you have in carboxylic
acid, you have an OR.
You have an oxygen with
an actual alkyl
group attached to it.
And this ester right here, and
we'll probably talk more about
esters in future videos, this
ester right here, just to give
you a hint of how to name it,
you first start with the group
that's attached to this
oxygen right here.
There are two carbons over
there, so we'll use ethyl to
name that over there.
And then we have the rest of
this, and we already know that
that is one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven carbons,
including the carbon in
the carbonyl group.
And so that is hepta-,
heptan-.
And you would be tempted to call
it heptanoic acid, but it
is no longer a carboxylic
acid.
It is now an ester.
So you call it heptanoate.
And this is what tells
you that you are
dealing with an ester.
And this tells you what's on the
other side of the oxygen
in the ester.
This is telling you how many
carbons you have attached to
the carbonyl chain of
the actual ester.
Anyway, hopefully, you
found that useful.
I just wanted introduce you
to a well-known reaction
mechanism of creating an ester
out a carboxylic acid.